When I just mentioned things like,
you know,
the greatest advancements in medicine,
technology,
science,
um,
basically human civilization has complimented particularly white men.
Uh,
I'm actually called a bigot and a Nazi and all sorts of things.
So I wonder if these words now outright this,
that have no power and they're just used against anyone who doesn't tow the
party line.
Yeah,
well they're definitely,
while in the thing about a thing about the,
the,
let's say the disproportionate contribution of European,
a small number of European men over the last 600 years,
something like that.
Maybe you could go all the way back to the Greeks if you're willing to call them
European,
which,
you know,
perhaps you could get away with.
Um,
it's a,
it's a drop in the ocean by historical standards.
And of course now that the entire world is linked together by,
by electronic communication and education is available to far more people,
you see that,
um,
contributions to the world's knowledge are being made at an incredible rate by
people all over the world.
And so now again,
it's a historical accident in some ways,
not precisely an accident,
but as historical accident.
Let's use that term that some of these technologies for learning and discovery
happened to be established in Europe and,
and that gave Europeans of technological advantage and also the opportunity to
contribute in a major way to new disciplines.
But that's being distributed.
Yeah.
Especially if you think origins,
like we have to give credit where credit's due,
like the Aba Aviation,
automobile,
uh,
many of the diseases cures like the origin really did come from Mensa matter how
much feminist rant and rave.
There is just no denying this,
that human societies have advanced tremendously because of these achievements.
Yeah,
there is no doubt about that.
And then it's,
yeah.
And that it's a relatively small number of people who've contributed immensely.
Well,
you see the same thing now you see the same thing now that there's a handful of
remarkable inventors that,
that are literally changing the world in front of our eyes.
And it is the case that it's often a very small number of people who change the
world in that manner.
So
look at Mark Zuckerberg.
I mean,
I was reading like Facebook is used by a billion people,
uh,
like a day,
or I don't know if it was a day or,
it's crazy number of people.
Astonishing.
Yeah.